You
Hello
Hi, I
Am trying to fix my headphones like fell out of my ear as I switch scenes
Hello
How's it going you get cozy epee madam today?
Real epee, but I'm excited
Oh, yeah, so sore I
Also, I'm sad cuz I left my gamer subs
Across the room. Let me go get that cuz I'm thirsty. I don't know why my eyes are so like
Half-lidded I like I have a light turned on. I don't know if maybe my glasses are reflecting
Too lazy to shove contacts in my eyes to fix them
As you can see I'm up here which lets people know that I'm still talking to y'all
And then once I move down all on mute all on deafen and you guys can't you'll be able to hear like fart noises
There's a lot of fart noises, let me turn off my BGM
Oh
My god
Okay
Yeah, there's a lot of fart noises in the game. I was I pointed out in our discord
I'm like you can still hear the fart noises when you deafen in game
Okay
Okay, let me just actually also quickly check on for you
How are you going tell me about your day
I
Had to flip her I have to flip her like she's a little like a little hamburger. She's a little borgger
Make sure she's good
Don't want her laying on the same side for like hours
Yeah, yesterday was really fun it feels like a dream feels like it didn't really happen
I
Super EP guys are EP2 we're gonna have a nice EP stream
I hope I can match the energy today for all the girls because I'm in the chat and I'm just like wow
It's also a lot of us and when there's a lot of people sometimes I get really shy
Um, and if it's like four people I'm like I'm okay, and I don't shut up or if it's a bunch. I'm just like
Oh
So, um, I hope you guys enjoy. I never played this game before. Um
I bet they're waiting for the rest of us. So I'm gonna move down
Um and go talk to the other girls. I'll try to like chat from time to time to you guys
Um and like mute so only you guys can hear and stuff
But ye I've texted voiced it. Um
Oh my god, push to talk turned on so that I have to push to talk because my ac would probably be funny and on the other girls streams
Okay
Oh, I'm nervous it's a lot of cool people here. This is a lot of sonic
This is a great thing to open to
Yeah, all right
I come back to shadow the headshot. Are we debating shadow the headshot for you?
Okay, pissing all by yourself handsome
Hot that's fine. All right. Anyways
A lot of things are working because everybody's deafened to do proximity chat
I just left it there. So you guys can see who's here. So can we start with uh
Discord order because that seems really easy. So I mean go first. I blasted discord. So is it here's the stage?
Yeah
Yeah, oh hi me. I'm Aimee. I'm from you. I post this first generation remedy. I'm an AI played up that. It's nice to meet you
My beloved
I bet I wonder what time it is for her because I don't know. Maybe it's super early. I'm not sure
I'm gonna check what time it is
I'll see you then
And I am the best duck tech
Oh my gosh
Ever seen
Get on stage
You can do it whatever whatever's comfortable
I left them locked
As your stage is up there go up past the monitor. Oh wait, I walk around aimlessly
Oh
I'm gonna introduce myself in an elu voice should I introduce myself in like a really funny voice?
I'm last so I gotta make it funny
Because this chord goes in alphabetical order
Although it's a momie's name and discord is something different. So
Hi
Girl
I'm so happy I turned down the volume
Oh
Hi, I'm Igna. Uh, I'm shy. Uh, I don't know English. Thank you. Good morning
Yay, yay, but in Spanish
I don't know
Thank you
Mercy
Yay
Hello, I'm mercy moe these from the alert gen one in dodge. I'm your dorky paun yandere
Oh my god
For timing
Oh
My ears are like I need to turn them down
Um, hi, oh, uh, my name is
She got all
And yeah, I'm nervous. Yeah
Oh
Yay in Spanish
Hi, everyone. My name is being cloud imparting me plus this first generation remedy. Thank you all so much for coming girlies
I really appreciate it. Let's let's roast some duck. Let's go
And then cb
Yeah
Hi, my name is she be cotton bum. I'm part of um
Indulge the veeler and I'm a totally say so bunny girl. Uh, it's really nice to be here. Okay. Bye. Such thing is a say so bunny girl
Exactly
Oh
As also a bunny girl, I don't trust your input on this
We're gonna start now so if everyone could press start game
So I can press start all players need to be ready. Yeah. Yeah. What are you?
Are we doing?
First one first one no roles just to get the newbies then the next one I'll do the roles
I think it says yeah, there's two people who have to ready up. Yeah
What is this I've never played this game before
I'm very say so what?
What the hey is this like is this like um
What's it called?
Maybe I should I should turn off push to talk because this is gonna be annoying. This is literally just among us
What is that? Can I touch it? Can I pick it up? Can I where's it? Can I use my mouse?
I don't know what to do
Activate teleporter
I have no idea what I'm doing
Can I not hear irie or maybe she also supposed to talk on
Can I honk no where are my tasks is this my task down here?
I'm assuming so
Oh
Did I just get murdered
What just happened
I have no idea what just happened
Since someone pressed a button and I got squished by something what
Oh
What the heck how big is this freaking map? Holy crap
So I was in the loading bay. Oh, this is so huge. Did they just kill me?
Did they do it on purpose it doesn't show if their ducks are gooses
Are we the sitting ducks and they're the I don't know how this works. This is really pretty though. This is literally what
This is really just a
Reskinned among us. I don't understand because this looks exactly like a different map and among us
the heck
I'm like 99% sure this is a map and among us. Am I tripping?
Oh, there the ducks
Look at them
First thing are you okay?
I was trying to speak the Spanish and then I got killed no and dies in Spanish
Let me turn off
Oh, let me see if I can test how do I test it?
I don't
Know how this works doesn't let me show
Okay, wait, wait, wait. Where was the body found? I mean, where was it found?
It was near the medical checkup place where I was doing
I think it was and there was a place with vines and stuff. I'm not very good. Let me check them up. It was near the
Of the bridge the blue area. Yeah, the bridge. Yeah, there there there
Just
I
I don't know what's happening. I'm so confused
I'm so sorry
Oh, yeah, I was gonna say um people be careful when you're trying to go from one side to the other
Apparently the ship will crush you. We want she be I um
We we ran her over she's a smear in the pavement. I mean, why would they call it?
Why would they call the ship if I'm sitting there cleaning stuff? They saw me on the platform
I don't know why like how are they?
And I they're not even the bad guys. They just straight up killed me. I love being alive
Oh, I'm a ghost
Can I talk in ghost?
Yeah, yeah, you can
Oh, I can talk in ghost. Anyways, I got killed in Spanish
I know I said dies in Spanish when you died
Ha ha ha
Did I do my task when I'm dead?
That's a great question
Oh, where the fuck am I? How'd I get out of here? I wish I could change the key. Wait, hold on. Maybe I can
Oh, I can like get out and just like float into places. I like to make pressure talk. I got it
Be for voice
I got it
Look at these look at these ducks just sitting here
Disgusting
Are both of them ducks?
There's three ducks. I didn't know wait. I thought there was only two. How is there three now?
Is that a thing? I mean, you know how if they're they're ducks or not. Oh, here we go
Because I'm standing near them and it says duck
No, no, oh god, I had to die
We how did I die from the dock? That's so stupid
What the hell
We people need to not do the tasks and then call the thing
Oh my god
Don't be you duck 40. I can hear you guys
Hello. Yeah, even it doesn't need proximity when you're dead
Oh, how did it got you to mommy?
It doesn't mean you all like them
It's cooking
To my tasks, I was like trying to find my task and she was like
And I was just like well
Where am I? I have to go all the way up there. This is such a huge map. I have to move so far. Okay
Where's my task gear?
I don't know what's happening
Oh, I thought it was mercy screaming. I'm sorry. It was not
Avian carcass found. I kind of wish we played them. I'll go
Superb like at least I don't have to play that game
Um
How could this happen to me
I'm just
Yes
I'm trying to figure out what's going on
I'm so lost guys. I'm so lost
Are we gonna all die?
Your order arrived today. What'd you order? What'd you order for your gamer subs? I'm drinking lean
I had the mango yesterday. The mango was really really good
I didn't want to drink an energy one before
You have to like walk over to
Whatever
Yeah, if you see something glowing you just hover over it
Okay, good luck queen. I am so confused about how to do these. I don't know what's happening either. I don't even
Where am I? Who am I?
It's also hard to find the task
What is this?
This is for smart people. Oh, okay
This will be fine. All right
That was really confusing for a second. I thought I had to like do some sort of matching thing
But a different sort of matching thing
Okay, okay. I see it. I see it. I want to do this. What are there's fake things that we have to do
understood
Orange
That's an inky bag
Okay, that'll just give me something to do so while I'm bored. This is kind of gross. I don't want to do it
Yes, I understand the task
I mean, oh, at least I can float through walls. Why could I float through one wall and not another?
But doesn't make any sense. Is this a shower? Okay. Ew
Wing ex
I can do this. I'm doing this. Why does that thing show up right there? I don't know
This one
Are you match up the lines? I'm trying to find the one that's where's the shuttle platform
I had to eat an egg
One more. I think one more. I think it was this one the one that I died at
Did you just what just happened over there? Did you just give birth?
Yeah, so did I
I highly don't don't ever stand over here
I did it. I did my task. I did my tasks
Also, I mentioned, hey, scion is messing with there's three ducks surrounding scion. I felt
There's three ducks surrounding scion that is must there I am
Shit
We're gonna get him
Oh my god, that was just me with all of the ducks
Never trust the spanish inquisition. It's the last time I show anyone anything I swear to god
Actually, I don't know if eggia speaks spanish. I know lia does
I can't believe I can't I can't believe you've done this
I'm so sorry. You did it in purpose. Didn't you you want to take me out of the picture then, huh?
Yeah, likely story
No one should ever give me the ability to drive
We're provoking your license
You missed me being accused in dying from being hit by a car
That's okay. I haven't had a chance to look at stuff because I've been busy
I can't believe I was showing you guys something
Okay, one scion sitting on it. No, I was dead. I was part of the
Wait, did we lose? I don't know. I didn't even see the spanish inquisition. I was looking at chat
I'll do random for some of them. All right. All right random guys. I'm so epee. I don't know what's going on
There's too many people. Mom, pick me up. I'm scared. That sounds good. You did win. Oh, I didn't know
Where's vulture? I thought I thought we lost because they were at the top. I guess not
I just did I was looking at the screen. I didn't read it. Okay
Oh, you can only have vulture. All right. Is this sound good by the way? Am I too loud or are they too loud?
Okay, are you guys are we smooching? Is this allowed?
It was an unmuted. Is there a way is there a way to
Lengthen the meeting time?
Yeah, yeah
Yeah, the meeting time was pretty
Wow, I have them halfway and they're a bit loud. I'm gonna turn them down some more for you though
60 seconds
So a minute and a half is that enough? Okay. Yeah
Oh, you know why do you have to sit on my headphones?
So the rules are random. You may or may not become a Canadian or a vulture or something else. Okay. What does that mean?
What does that even mean?
Give me my green card. I'm uh, what?
I'm always a comedian
Oh, what's the deal with airplane food? I'm just gonna leave
Can I throw myself out the window is that a thing?
Okay, everyone's starting
Stairs at Azura lovingly
Affectionately I'm a goose
Okay
Okay, at least it closed like I'm close to my first thing I ran out on my lap Tomomi's right there
I can't even click it Tomomi just did it
Tomomi took my task
I didn't think that was a thing
I'm not even supposed to be here. Where am I?
Uh, okay. I have something to do in the bio lab, which is up here
What you
Okay, I I can probably vouch for Tomomi if Tomomi's fine or they would have killed me by now
My little little tomboy
In girly pop. All right, so that's good
um
All right, probably just need to go to the teleporter. Does it teleport me? So does it teleport me across?
There's a bar there. I can't walk
Oh ain't that nifty. Can I freaking leave? Uh, okay, let's go up here because I see a yellow dot
I love Tomomi Tomomi's voice is cute
Oh
Hello
Uh, I feel like I'm standing where I'm supposed to be the tasks again are very hard to get to
How I do I have to
What do I have to adjust to no, am I being surrounded?
I mean, I mean, I swear to god, you're you've given me PTSD
Stay away from me
I don't even know how to do this stupid task
What the heck
Why is the sn boobs?
You know, what is it? What's it? I can't tell how do I change the temperature? It's just showing me them
Hello, hi rain. Oh water them. I have the water but no, it's telling me to change the temperature
I don't know what to change the temperature to it just says s slash n boobs
boobies bottom gotta match the top. Oh
I figured it out. I figured out the temperature
I'm wicked smart
As they say I'm bastard
uh, well
Hello, you have the same task
I just I just checked in Ryan Goosling. Uh, I also have to check in Ryan Goosling
That just scared the crap out of me
What was that screaming noise? Why is everybody dead?
I'm like the two people I hung out with for a small amount of time are dead
Wait, I realized I said that and it sounds weird. No because I was saying to my chat
I was like, oh, I can vouch for tomomi and scion and then they're dead now. So
Yeah, I don't know who it was but naya and I were down and where is that naya?
I we just ran into the body into part your day
You guys saw me struggling with the temperature thing, please
I don't think it I don't think it's meadow because I saw meadow. I think it was she'd be earlier
Yeah, mero was chillin me. We were doing tasks together
It's freaking I something tells me it's Imi
I don't know. I feel it. I feel it in my belly button
Wait, wait, you have to tell us why though. No, I just I just said I just don't trust her from the amaga school
Okay, I don't
Mercy is literally a yandere and captures people. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Oh was I supposed I don't even know how to vote
How do I vote?
That's why I tried talking to irie that makes sense then
Okay
Oh, I don't even know what just happened
Hello. Hi. Hi. Hi. Welcome in. We still don't know who it is then. Oh my god. Hey rain. Why don't you come with me?
Because let's let's not you is it off. No, I I don't I trust you
Okay, I don't trust listen. I don't think it's meadow
But I haven't seen Imi. I haven't seen Imi very often in this round
But Imi creeped up behind me
Then mero was there and so I feel like she like ran away
Dang when I was feel messing up, you know, yeah, that's real funny. That's real funny
I can't believe this
Oh
Sion
I'm scared at me
I don't know if they can hear me
I hate you. I hate you so much. I hate you so much rain. I hope you can hear me
I hope you can hear me rain. Look what this happened. She's waiting to self
She's waiting to pretend to stumble upon my freaking body. She's about to be like, oh, I didn't know this was there
Oh, I am rain. I'm a pretty little princess
What she can't even do the teleport right?
So I am so quiet I'm nervous I was played like a fiddle
Is she trying to kill herself what's happening here?
Why did you do that?
I'm watching you just kill yourself
I'm you know what you deserve that karma, you know, I've been screaming at you for the past like minute
You're dead to me rain
He said it was too easy. She was the only one here with me. I had to
I had to it was too perfect
Sion you see in this shit sion you're so quiet
I
I didn't know how you're supposed to go down here first. Okay. No, I got it. I understand though. Is sion muted?
Is sion muted? Oh, you're quiet. I think she might be muted. Hello. I am muted because I'm a fucking idiot
I've really been talking to you sion and you haven't been responding
I I've been responding just not not
Audibly apparently
I had a conversation about how that exact smudge on the floor was what she be was
In the last round. Oh, true. The last she be hot. You've happened to you too
Yeah, but only because I was cleaning it and you guys called it and killed me
Yeah, and then we warned you rain. So I don't know like she be at least
Why does it cut people off like that?
I
Taking credit for rain's death
I killed rain. I didn't but I like to say I did
Rain killed herself she couldn't take the pressure
I don't know if they can actually dead people can hear each other in the chat
Wait, is there only two what's a dodo bird? How did
What does that even do?
What are the roles mean?
No
How did I read this connect?
Yeah, before everything I was hanging out with mira
I also haven't seen coconut like
Oh my god, it's gonna be so funny when serenity or mercy they have to turn to one just like kill each other
It's gonna it's gonna be like hunger games
To the stars team rocket blasting off again
Oh my god the screaming
I'm taking credit for that kill I'm to it's me. I haunted the train and got you to kill yourself in minecraft
I'm sorry my wrathful ghost. She led me. I trusted her
I keep getting betrayed
I like how it does a dramatic zoom when you walk away watching if I step over here
Wait, hold on
I think oh, yeah
Oh my god
This is their trauma. This is when we grow boss gay keep
Yes gaslight and I gaslight her isp
Yeah
I'm not an easy target. I'm just very trusting. Okay
And give people the benefit of you know, it's funny because I was sitting with rain and I'm like wait
I literally have to go with my gut
Because at some point I was when I was alone with rain after she stopped to hang out with me and I said rain come back here
I like
felt like
I felt like I was just like, why did she she's like, I don't know. I just had a weird feeling
I
Can't even do that. Are you winning mom joke because madame is actually winning. I'm not even doing anything. I'm dying so early
The scion's outfit scion looks so cute. Oh my god
I'm a pretty pretty princess
I could I could be I like that voice. Sorry. I had to mimic it
That's that's the echolalia for you
I'm the Luigi. Oh
I'm a pimp and a detective. I'm gonna cry in this corner. It's still broke. How do you get far?
Oh, I can get money
You have to enable it
I can have a poopy bronze
All of a poopy bronze
I don't have any farts
It's firing in the shot. I have to make my own fart noises. Oh, yeah, it is in the shot
This one's great too. Oh
I want to be a maid so bad. I want the bead claw
I just want to be a maid
Yeah, I thought that you could pick some things but now it's my strategy
Oh the putt raised crystal ball into the stratosphere. I'm gonna grab some water if you're weak
Put my normal outfit on
I'll just bend it. I don't know when I'll be back
Scion just turned into an emo kid. I don't know what you're talking about. This is my usual outfit
Where are you?
Oh
Check yes, Juliet. Are you with me?
If I were gonna do the Hannah Montana transition song
Well, yeah
Rain is falling down
Why am I peeking my mic so much? I'm so sorry
Oh my gosh, it's all gotcha
Yeah, rain is yeah
There used to be like an actual store
But now it's gotcha on dust, I guess because I guess that means if people play it on but don't spend money
They can use all of their silver
To get dust and spend it question mark question mark. What a terrible system. Yes
You traded my life for 30 pieces of silver you Judas you traitor
What's up be right in the back
I can I can be an exhibitionist just a little longer if I spent 4 000 dust. I can get a police hat
If I spend 20
That doesn't sound like it if I kill myself
Get me out of here. It's so expensive to be an e-girl. Oh, I can hear them. I feel like people are getting outfits that I don't see
Wait, if I pay a thousand dust I can become a cultist
That's pretty nice. You can also become the lord of morgore
Why is there a morgore right here? What? I want to be a freaking shark
I want to be a gragora. It's 20 bucks. I'm not spending 20 bucks though. Oh, there's a chandelier hat
It's a dust shop. I became a cultist. How do I get dust? I want this piece of bread on my head
How do I get like I how where do where do I spend the real money? Like how does this translate to that?
This is from levels. This is from money. What does this do?
Like the most of the transactions
I'll do whatever this is
Are we starting or are we waiting? I'm just waiting. I don't know what this means. Okay. Okay. Hold on. She's typing something
I'm typing
I got seven dust
What does that do his mermaid makes me happy. I don't know. He's such a pretty mirror. I need 150 of that
That is the stupidest thing ever
What is this stupid ass break? I'm so frustrated right now
I just want to spend money. Wait, wait stand next to kakone and I can have a sushi train for me. Maybe I'll just buy
I
Could be a little sailor duck delicious
We fi we fi we fi we fi we fi
Oh, she only has mobile like fortune teller. Oh, no. Tell me your greatest secrets
What this isn't given up money
We'll do another game and then I'll check on you. Okay. Okay
That's high. Let me get real money. My debut is hella scuffed. It was bad. So I can spend
2,000 coins if I spend a hundred dollars and they give me nothing. That sounds pretty decent. It's to call it the IHOP the international house of pain
That's about right, but let's go. I'll start game everyone, please. Okay, let's go
On gbd drink it
I know this it's also giving me a little bit of sensory overload with the sound. That's why sometimes I just like zone out
Hello
If it isn't the mama me
And I am in me
What does this do? Oh, I'm supposed to hit the bags the heck
I just squashed some ants
My hand like a boss. Stay away from me rain
Oh
I don't trust her I don't trust her one bit. I'm surprised I haven't been made a thing yet. What select
What
Some of these tasks are confusing I I'm a simple girl
Very simple minded
Because I'm like, do I do these in order? I don't think I do. I think I'm just supposed to go through them
What the heck
Sometimes my thing clicks too fast. That took too long
I'm so too wait. I heard someone say no. Who was that? Are they dead?
I me I hear you
I don't know where she is
Why oh what's going on in here to cover that buck quack
I'm telling a jerk to reassure zura. I'm safe
So I said why did ducks cover the
Why did ducks have tails and is to cover the butt quack? Oh, you're so funny. I'll see I'll see you later
Oh, I'm really so cute. She has the cutest voice in my opinion
I
Just fed some fishies that was pretty neat
Calibration station
Oh, do I have to do that then do that whatever that doesn't make any sense. Um
I have so much to do over here
I have to go to agriculture. I thought hey
Tiptoe
I thought it was already over here the heck
Oh
I'm so talented at my job
I
Hear people
No, I'm running. I'm running. I don't trust this
No, well, I'm he's dead. That sucks for her. Hi, mero. It's just me. You're fine
Naya just walked past me mero come back
Stick together stick together
My mero this time. I promise you
Naya walked past me and she chased me for a little bit
She did her her and imy were like ganging up. No, they're ganging up on imy her and somebody else. I don't know who it was though
All right, I leave them in peace
I'm focused on doing what is this ready?
Who am I calling
Why is this in japanese has an intruder
What oh I thought you said my mom do you remember to feed the cat
It's been years you've been watching lately
The news
Dang, okay. Bye
Who did I call?
What family member is so rude?
All right, uh, I don't even know what's happening. I feel like I should be looking around
And seeing where people are
I was just doing my task
Okay, I'm gonna be from them for a second. Thank you for the dono
It's hard to see. I'll probably read donos at the end. They are screaming right now. You guys can't hear
Y'all too long
I'm he was imy was biting her time. I saw you guys were all surrounding you and i you were trying to go after nia
I knew it. I knew they were gonna double
I saw the double team happening and I ran away from them
I
Will be
One of the killing
All right, okay, okay, okay, okay
Or a blankie
It's a blankie
Do I have money now? Can I play with money? Fuck? I mean
Oh, I shouldn't swear. I mean frick
Wait, are we not supposed to be swearing because I'm sorry if that is the case
I don't know I don't know
Feel free to swear, baby. Okay. Okay. Okay. Thanks shit. Thanks shit
Okay
Is that the number? Oh, what is this?
I
Don't think that I think that's the number of ducks killed
I think rain got kicked out of the room
Oh
Yeah, so, uh, I think she's put a new room for us to go to
Remember to cover your thingy when you put in the I always cover my thingy. How do I how do I get out?
How do I get out of here?
Like how do I leave
There's a door in the top left main menu settings. Yeah
All right, I'm gonna hide my screen for a second
Oh
No, I think maybe she got disconnected. Oh my god, everybody's screaming
The tents
So tense
Oh
I'm trying not to over-stimulate
Let me over-stimulate it
I have them at half
I'm here wait if she's
Why isn't she loaded in if it's her room? That's very interesting. Wait. Yeah
Because like that was the same code as the old one
Oh my gosh, okay. Well later alligators
What?
I'm so confused. Yeah
Wait, who's the host?
Who's the host?
Okay, yes, what is this the omega? Hold on. Nobody can hear me. Nobody can hear my funny joke
Is this the omega verse?
Is this the omega verse but geese?
I'm an alpha
I'm an alpha male
Who wants to be my discord kitten?
Me
So eager she is an alpha. I'll buy you all the nice skin baby girl
Yeah, you want the pink mercy skin? I got you
No, we are a little discreet
Actually, you know what I'm a sigma
Sigma ball
Okay
Oh, yeah
First order as alpha of the geese pack
Everybody kiss the person to your left
Everybody's leaving
It's also like kind of sucks because I like I try to do a joke but sometimes the joke can't land because everybody's like
Ow, I just hit my oh, I just hit my wrist really hard against my
Desk oh
Oh
That hurt a lot
A psionid raider unmuted
Are you okay? Yeah, I'm fine. I kind of wish I slammed it harder
Let me know a let me explain
So like I have like the beginning of one of those like
bumps on your wrist
Because my joints are are messed up and so some normally sometimes you can take a giant like book and like slam it down
on
And like pop pop it
Last time I because I'm a weirdo
I took a syringe and I drew out the liquid from it myself and then it went away for a bit
But then it came back because you need to get them. It's a ganglion cyst
It's just like your joint fluid seeps out of your joint. They're very very common. Um
It's like a clear liquid
Yeah, you can't see though like you guys have seen my hands you can't see it's only when I like really bend my wrist that you can see
It's like a little divot
But yeah, no, I like took a
I took a needle and I drew out the liquid and I'm like, oh, yeah
I watched like a youtube video of some dude like he just like slammed it with a bible
Like a giant. No, it was this I watched this video
Yeah, this I think it was like this lady and her husband
She like slams a bible on the one on his wrist and it pops and it was insane
um
How much you want my joint fluid how much for the fluid and then another one
I just you just see this guy like his dirty bedroom and he's like
So, yeah, you're gonna take an alcohol pad and you're gonna wipe the area
And then you're gonna take a needle and then you're gonna draw out the needle
You draw the liquid through the needle
You can pop it
It was really weird because it's like a perfectly clear liquid
It looks like a like a clear gel
No, we're not that kind of bible
You freaks
Wait, did they post the new discord? No, I mean the new room
Okay
I'm gonna take a moment
But here. No, I actually know my camera is not connected right now or I'd show you guys
um
Yeah
I think it's a bodily fluid here. I wouldn't want to buy truth. All right. I'm mentally preparing myself to go into this
Very loud room
Yeah, the better results here, you know
But like I also don't want like to get up my
I don't want to get my um
Like have an actual surgery on my wrist for assist because it like I could just keep
Drawing out the liquid. I haven't done it in a while or I could smack it
Oh, that actually hurts
It's like a weird bump
I'll stuff it in my mouth. Yeah, I need to be ready
Really bro, I still don't know what that means. Really. I'm not gonna spell it. Nobody spoon feed them. Nobody spoon feed
No, that's tracking you doesn't help that
Yes, sir
Is this where the farts are
What's a fought?
Oh, okay, I thought I was like the the goose equivalent of a thought it's just a fought
What
Did not catch that can I please be something other than a goose
Oh
I'm gonna haunt it
Oh, hey, what's up
And good luck
They're trying to figure that out. So wait, who was that that was
That was nia and I think it was
No, I don't I can't remember. Yeah, it was okay. It was nia and marrow
Um, so they're probably good
And I have the popcorn now
Making popcorn. Yeah, I'm making popcorn, but how do I make the popcorn and pop? I don't know. Did I do it?
How does it pop?
I just press the button someone else pop it
But how do we make it pop? I don't know. It's it looks like it's popping. Maybe you have to like wait for it
I hope maybe you're trapped to try not to burn it burn it. Do you have to like unpress the button on the top left top left?
I can't see a left
I hope I don't burn the popcorn
Hey, what is she doing? Okay, I'll wait 10
9 8 7 oh screen is all black. Oh, that's awkward. Anyways
2 1
What am I what is this stupid egg my my killing eggs these duck eggs?
I hate it
Okay, well
Do I have to get like a thing wait mercy? How did you do this?
How did you do the I took the stick and I like spun it? No, no, no, not the not the cotton candy the the popcorn one
I still don't get it
You see where the duties list is there should be a little like number and it's going down
I'll see that
Okay, do you see your duties? Yeah, I see clean tiger poop make-on candy. Oh wait, did I already I think I might have already did it
All right, never mind
Okay, so I think mercy's good because me and her are both struggling with that
What is happening? What is she?
I'm making a beautiful painting
All right, I'll see you. I don't know what Ozzy's doing
What is this
Catch rabbits. Oh, that just scared me
What rabbits are we catching?
Why is this guy cracked out
Wait, did I
What do you have to say
Rabbits
I knew I should have stuck before okay, okay, okay killed her cold blood
You can the thing about lovers is when one person dies the other one also dies wait, who are we voting for?
Oh
All right, then it's serenity and I mean
Get away from me get away from me you too. I don't trust either one of you
Work work work. Okay, mercy. I trust you. We have like the same task
Oh, yeah, tiger, but it's not tamola
Well, I found it. I think this is the one I totally messed it up
I gotta go I gotta go back. I gotta go back. I gotta go back. I got it. I have to go dress up. What does dress up?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, where's where's she? Where is she? Where is who?
No, no, mercy. Mercy. I want mercy. Run. Mercy
Don't let them kill it. I feel like it's definitely I mean serenity
You think so I do but they love me
That doesn't matter in this game of life or death. Love is not an option
Okay, I'll come with you
You're almost done our tasks
I'm gonna guard you
Actually, I have something down here in the tent, but I don't want to leave you so I want to sit right here
I'm scared
Wait
Oh
Okay, Nia was doing the ring toss
No, I came from the casino. I mean, I was in the casino with rain and rain sound silly
Nia was doing the ring toss
Yeah, let's just do this again. Nia was using the ring toss. I was with she be but I was doing the fortune thing
Well, Nia speaks mostly Spanish
I feel like it's serenity and I mean they look really suspicious
I don't know about that. That sounds like someone who killed a Zura would say
Likely
What does that mean
Uh
Mercy
No
Oh
Why do I gotta shoot tiger poop? This is the grossest thing ever. I don't like it
We're almost done our tasks
What rabbit
No, no, oh no, oh no rain. Am I supposed to catch you?
Let me catch you. I'm not gonna. No, no, no, no, no, no, no
It's rain. It's rain. It's rain guys. It's rain rain. It's rain. It's rain. It's rain. It's not me. It's not me
You're gonna see dead bodies and it's not for me
Okay, I wasn't right. I knew it. I knew it was I mean
I don't even I don't know what the roles are
I am murdered me
I don't know what's happening. I think
Maybe if I can add a new role here, there might be not enough tasks. Yeah, let me increase the mask. We keep getting task wins. Yeah
Yeah, I'm gonna do y'all are too slow
March I think
Can you not
Is it because I'm rain and I mean just constantly I believe are always
The people because they just they're just such good. I don't trust them from
My three killers. I think three killers is a little too much. So much. Yeah. Yeah
It's large now X this is regular large not extra
Snacks
When I saw Deadpool, yes, I got peanuts. I got chocolate covered peanuts eat four corpses to win
Okay
What's a vulture to do?
Oh, so I really don't have to do anything. I have to eat people
I heard going up to get some water
It's fine
They can't kill me right
Because then I might just get up to get some water
I'm eating airheads. I'm a corpse eater call me dung eater the way I desecrate that
Oh my god, why do I keep getting jumpscared by the roller coaster?
Let's pop in
All the life
Let's go meeting bell. I don't think I have to do that
Pretend I'm talking to the fortune teller how I'm supposed to eat a body
The task sucks, yeah, it's annoying gotta crack the egg or whatever it is
You open this bag
Naya
I want to do this
I'm sorry. I'm I'm eating snacks. So I paused
Oh time to eat
Wait a second. I saw Naya just with igna first right before
And then she cornered me
Let me stare at each other the roller coaster
Yes, I've been riding the roller coaster
You can actually
I think you're the dodo. I think you're the dodo. I'm just chilling
It's not I need this time. What does a dodo do? It's not I mean because I mean I were doing
I can't open this bag. I mean keep on getting getting getting the villain this time
I want to be the bill. I want to be a killer
Not this whatever this bowl is
Let's go let Naya kill more people
Oh no
Sorry, I'm eating peanuts. I'm gonna stay with you. I gotta go down here
Follow Naya. You're so right though
And then
It's like a smoothie
What no
I didn't know how to get on
Um looking for people to eat this map is so huge wait Jesus
Okay, Naya was over here. Wait, is this pointing me towards a corpse?
Oh
How do we eat it? Oh
No, well, I'm just standing next to it
I definitely saw that
I definitely saw me just standing next to it
Seven I uh
What?
Oh, is it in here?
Well, we were on the roller coaster. I saw she be standing over a dead. I was running over to the bow
Oh
No, I'm I'm a vulture. I'm just eating
I'm a vulture whatever I ate two bodies
They're very delicious
No, I'm sorry
What what happens if I get voted off and I'm a vulture, I don't know what happens
Well later
I'm dead
I
Did anything happen?
I'm uh, should be got killed
Yeah, does it tell you whether or not she wish you
She's just a vulture
We tell you what
I was a vulture
Who's the what their thing is? Oh my gosh, it's bubble tea
It's azu and um, you have to like look at the person and it'll tell you who it is
She is snacking I'm just like, uh, gotta eat these chocolate covered peanuts
What?
I must I must I must discuss. What is the lover?
Naio is the only one with her
There's only one duck
I was achieving that moment and now she reads that
The fact that it's not naio is actually really surprising
I'm gonna get
I can see naio
You're gonna repent this
You are my always my favorite snake girl
Are you surprised? Bye
I
Turned on the light. I mean the fans
Yay
Why did she vote herself out?
Naio, why did you vote yourself out?
Wait, uh, um, I don't understand
I am
Oh, why do you vote yourself out?
Um, I think I did it by you know, ever
It's not azura because she was with me
Exactly
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Wait, wait, wait. Tommie was the Canadian
No, no this last round, wasn't it?
Oh, well, she wasn't it this year. No, I'm she's been two rounds where Tommie is
Yelling at me that she is the canadian do not touch me in the canadian one was a
Okay, you thought it was me, but maybe it's Azura?
As it was really good, this game.
No, no, no, wait!
Rain!
The Canadian!
Tamale is the Canadian!
Meaning it's coconut senpai!
I need the skits earlier.
It's the person who reported the body.
It's coconut senpai.
Oh, she was yelling.
She was literally running around, yelling at.
Hakone, I'm so sorry.
I'm cuckoo for coconuts, but I'm so sorry.
Wait!
You can't, though, because I'm Metal's lover.
If you vote me out, Metal dies too.
No!
Baby, go!
Metal!
Let me go!
What does the lover do?
Like us?
Honey?
No!
Uh oh, Kocone.
Chestnuts resting on an open.
Chestnuts.
Thank you.
Okay.
A.K.A.
Breastnuts.
Where is the garlic?
It's still going, because there's one more thing.
one more but it is still one more person outside of yeah anyways I want to do my
fake tasks
as he was trying her darned is sorry I'm chewing so freaking loud no we can't
hear you okay this is so hard I did it I did it I need to play basketball now
basketball basketball this I think this is gonna be the first time the killers
might actually win yeah as there is very good at these games this is like a
really hard like situation for us cuz they're all sticking together yeah you
might as well just kill them oh okay got you just to cheapies my idol oh sorry
I haven't eaten since like three so I'm like I need to something wait can we still
do our tasks and win are they all fake tasks
yeah I suppose we're free from I love that I just fly off the map and just
disappear into the void oh my god they're on the roller coaster
Azura is she gonna do it Azura is trying so hard I think she's trying to
get on it oh my god is she gonna do it you're gonna do it
yeah why haven't any we're gonna just watch what happened they called them
eating it wait for the thing to come and then just like kill one of them as it
comes by fast enough I think that's what she tried before and they jump back in
too fast
she just missed the other train and not train I mean roller coaster
oh my god is her just kill them
rain didn't you say you were gonna go hit the bell yeah I didn't know I didn't
know where it was I believe I didn't see rain at all
I was I did not take the map where's where's the button
yeah no I bought this outfit today as part of the pack because it I thought it
looked like my hair that's why I bought it oh yeah kind of does I think it's a
little like you guys said it's not me you guys said it was me it's you are you
too no no Serenity come on if it was you I'm glad you didn't kill me thank you
oh my god it's not me I swear she lied as easily as she breathed she lied as
easily as she breathed she lied as easily as she breathed no cuz you
literally see Serenity hop on the train a bunch of times like she's scared of
a Zura so I'm like where are they I wish when you died you could see where
okay listen a Zura I'm sorry like I trusted you but I think the colony was
on to something because I mean when she said that she said it was you she said
I mean to be fair I don't care who cook one day somebody said it was because
she's evil but the way that you interacted with me just then was really
sucks I was only asking you if you thought it was me oh my god I'm listening
I'm listening closely to a Zura's voice how she lies her voice gets higher
so yeah I told you I was a vulture oh my god there's screaming again
I was chasing on the roller coaster I just want to I just want to be able to
kill people I just want to can I please be a duck that was I just want to be a
duck I thought I could trust you we were together most of that game I feel like
the game like peaks everybody's make sure I can't fire you were actually yelling
that you were the Canadian for real and it wasn't all in my head cuz I was like when
people were like that was another game I was like was it because if it was I'm
gonna kill coconut I can't find any I haven't lost any parts very dummy in my
opinion I thought everybody was just ignoring me because they hate me but I'm
being like targeted because like why is the Canadian getting Canadian
Canadian is if someone kills you then that is so funny I thought this was
Canadian crime I was I was like an assassin I was like running around
just slicing as one does one more here then I'll try to switch it okay you're
all screaming watching you get on the roller coaster
what up girl that's up why are you so close to me you're making me nervous
hypothetically I am you know please please say oh guys mercy ask me a
hypothetical question as if she was the killer just saying mercy's a little suss
when she's I was literally gonna kill mercy the moment my thing went off she
is so lucky she is so lucky that people walk over yeah well I'm on a never-ending
quest to find my lover oh anyways if you want to be my hypothetical get away
all right let me find someone that's alone which should be pretty easy at least
I gave you like fake tasks it's a little bit more convincing where the heck I
just want to find somebody alone what is happening over here okay well I'm so
sorry now oh yeah I want to do it I'm trying to close what what what wait do
they see me what are they going for the bell okay I don't know where to go this
back is so big they got a pee guys hello
okay so serenity and mercy you guys were sitting there like I don't know making
out or whatever in the corner did you not see that body they didn't see it they
didn't see it they didn't see it I was busy it's mercy she's jealous of serenity
and how did I do that no mercy mercy explain yourself I want more I want more
mercy before I make my verdict no no mercy you were chasing me around and
you're like
What's the dodo do?
Oh it's- I'm sorry.
It's just a little f***ing off.
Maybe Mercy's gonna love you.
I don't know how to undo stuff, then.
I can't even undo.
You can't undo if you voted, you voted.
I'm so sorry!
Oh you're fine.
Oh no, you're not fine.
Oh rip.
I see, you can't f*** around like that, okay?
Oh damn it.
Damn it, damn it, damn it, damn it.
Okay, whatever I'm sorry, I like chocolate rabbits what bunnies excuse me am I being fetishized oh
Oh
Maro you've been pretty quiet
Yeah
All right, I mean you're good you're cool in my book I mean
Marcy Marcy I was waiting for us to be alone so he could be like oh hypothetically and then I just kill you but and people kept walking over I
Mean I saw
What a freaking thing oh
Oh, I was yeah, I was hoping that she wasn't on cool down really good you double-edged us. That was crazy. Yeah
I killed Azura and I accidentally did it right next to a bunch of you guys and none of you know
I didn't know there's like two people above it
I think they're everybody was so wrapped up in their time
Adorable I still can't get the main outfit
Oh
Here we missing someone
I want to fart so bad man
Oh
That was pretty good if anybody wants to highlight
Although no my lips. That's literally the only high couple moment though
Because I haven't been able to do much. Please duck. Yes
What is this water noise
Where am I where are we? Oh, we're back at the that place. That's so weird
Hello
Hey, there's somebody over there. I'm unsure though
They see pretty suspicious
I'm being decontaminated. It's gonna kill me
I don't know what's happening here. Oh, I'm decontaminated. I don't know what that means
Yeah, I walked through here to just like decontaminated me
All right, I was gonna get
What's going on over here, what are you guys giggling about I'm scared I'm running away
Don't get don't get hit by the thing though
Okay, and I know they're down there and they'll know it's me if I do
Yo guys guys
How do what how do I report?
Okay, okay
Can I please talk can I please talk? Okay, so you guys were hanging out by the transporter and I told you guys
You know, don't get killed. I run up
I go to the side and then I see the wait who was it that died
It was cacone dead in there and I was screaming and I'm like what's happening. Wait, how do I report a body?
Cuz like
Please no, I seriously did it. I didn't even kill them
I live
You might know how I think it's she be is why there was only four of us on that side of the who was the other person
Who was the other person?
No, there was one there's one more person with us. I saw them. They teleported
Got no guys. I'm serious. I was not me
I mean
If it's not you then it's on it. It was so it was okay
It was a Zura and I me and then there's also
Cacone and if there's another person I don't know who it was. Oh my god. I didn't even kill them
I didn't even kill them
It's fine
I I didn't need to kill them. I didn't even kill them
She be if you didn't kill them
Sorry, you were saying something
What'd you say mercy?
Wait, there we go. I hate this temperature thing so much. I got a question
What's up, Naya?
Ryan Goosling
Oh
I'm trying to think of a geese related
Names that could be the movies guys. I can't kill them because tomomi isn't here
The barbie movie, uh, the beast movie the bar beast movie
How do I how do we do stuff?
guys
Where is it?
Where is it? Where is it?
I need to do it
Guys
Tomomi is fucking things up with you
No, it's not got you saw tomomi run by
You literally saw her run by me and she did
I was just mercy mercy mercy and naya can vouch that I was literally with them
Doing the temperature thing
Please I am literally just keep getting framed
Guys it's not
It's not me it's tomomi
Hey
I can't believe this
I didn't even kill them. I didn't even kill them
I
Am so upset
I didn't even kill any of you guys tomomi kept fucking me every time
I didn't even kill I was just minding my own business waiting for my moment and then tomomi
Then maro ran away. We're about to do a double kill because she did it too early
It's it's tomomi then it's you tomomi. You self-reported. I mean I got that
I thought I could I thought I could do the deflects where I blame my teammate and then somebody else
Please let me speak. Okay. This is this is kind of funny. It's not really funny. Um, I'm gonna be honest
I've done all the killing and you guys blame. She both of my
Just walked by
Tomomi
I didn't even kill anybody I literally
Yeah, but I didn't I didn't act on my murderous urges. I didn't act on my murderous urges
No, no, but still guys. No guys tomomi. It wasn't lying. I I literally didn't kill any of you guys
Every time
I happened to walk by and I was like we weren't even like like maro
Uh, I was trying to get maro to do a double team with tomomi, but she ran away too fast
And then I got blamed for it
Cause they died as soon as your body was on top of their body. Yeah. No, I like how it looked
I saw it happen and I'm like, oh great. Yeah. Yeah. Oh great
Tomomi just messed up. I forgot her hair. Tomomi
When tv god spell I I felt her heart, you know being hurt. I feel her anger
No, because it was true. I was so angry because I didn't even kill love
I didn't have to say I do have to say mercy. I promise and serenity can vouch
She wanted to die because she wanted me to weekend at bernie's her. So I didn't kill her
She was what she wanted. I wouldn't have done. Okay. That's what you want. Okay. I'm sorry. I'm like
And I said if you're the killer, can you weekend up bernie is my body like put me somewhere funny?
I wish you could move the body around
If you could move bodies, that would be a very interesting dynamic
I got scared
I need to be a duck again so I can be redeemed
I blame
I just wanted to vote it out
Why
It's quite fitting
Any other role which is surprising
I'm scratching my eye
Oh
I'm turning them on
This might be my last game because I have to go
How can you can eat people but it's not you're not an evil
Oh my god, boy, she's picking her mic with her
Yes, and it's really I know PTT would be so funny. I might try to put that together
Please let me be a duck. I'm an Avenger
Avengers assemble
You
Like
No, we're talking about last game
And I want to eat it. I mean what excuse me what
I'm waiting for one of you guys to die so I can witness it
And avenge the murder because I'm an Avenger like that. Tell me that was very impressive. Do you want to kiss me?
We should kiss I want to kiss you
Let me set up the camera. I just wanted to applaud you. Yeah, but I'll tag you guys on a special blue website for this clip
Thank you. Thank you very much
Can I tell you guys my role?
Yeah, who's the other Dodo I'm an Avenger
assemble
Wait, what the hell are you guys whispering about?
I actually
Well, I'm scared to tell you guys sign. Tell me what she is, but I'm scared to tell you guys because I don't know who you are
I'm an Avenger. I'm trying to duel my other Dodo
Oh, you should be doing things then dude. If you're dueling
You're gonna die. I'm gonna die
Yeah, you're dueling
Well
Oh, how you guys doing
I want to
Are you guys what are you guys's roles?
Roll
I am an Avenger and I'm forming a team
Good luck with that. I have to read you guys don't want to join the Avengers
No
Wait, if I can temporarily kill people after I witness a murder then does that mean then does that mean what?
What do you mean from when are you literally okay?
Yeah, I was in communications talking to rain and I was like, can you help me can you help me find
And I was like I like rain's voice
And I saw him walking away from the body directly and also I'm the detective
So if you somehow get out of this, I'm gonna fucking be on your ass. Okay, so you wait
I was just wasn't I just Maro in a cacune
Oh, okay
Uh, I believe that's probably Tomomi
I bet some of me is not a detective. She's the dodo self report. I'm a skip
Same
Is that what it's called
Don't worry, don't worry. I'm an Avenger. So if I witness your murder if I witness your murder, I can avenge you
Hello, oh, thank you
All right, we got to go find Maro
And so I can if she murders somebody I could witness the murder and I can avenge and I think that means I can kill the murderer
I sign on a sheriff. So I can just I could just fucking kill her. Oh wait, you can
All right, she has a gun
What you do when I'm me
I
Mean are you alive?
Let's see if I can line up with her
What are you doing?
What are you doing your eafk?
I was astral projecting apparently. What are you like a psychic or something?
I think so I can use my spirit to go through walls, but I can't see like oh, okay
Okay, I think I think you're good then that's pretty cool. I know I know I had to do the I had to do a task there
One of you guys kill somebody so that I can avenge them and kill you
Oh, hi, I want to go on this thing
Wait a second
She did say that to me
yeah
If because you know about this game if I'm the detective and I scan someone and there's like a little angry face next to them
Does that just mean that they killed or does it also mean they're a bad guy?
It just means they killed someone
I think serenity
I think serenity is good
We were close we were walking around together alone for a while and I'm an avenger and we were just like, okay
We're gonna go kill mero
That sounds bad, but um that was the safest way to do it anyway. Yeah
So I think yeah, I I think I think serenity is I
Yeah
She literally told me she was the sheriff as soon as the game started. Okay, and I told you who I vote. Do I just skip you trust
Okay, so does that mean it was not the serenity is not a good liar? So yeah
She's really not a good liar. No, it just means she wasn't a who's the one person that voted. Okay. Okay. Okay
Azura's mighty quiet. Naya's mighty quiet
Wow
Uh-huh
All right, kakune
What just happened wait, what just happened?
Who is in there? Hello?
Well, who's in the thingy? Oh, it's azura. It's azura
Wait, it's definitely not me. No, I meant like it's azura like she's here
Like uh, it's azura
If you do kill somebody I'm just gonna wait for it to happen. So uh, you can't I can avenge them
How do we fix the lights? Oh, are they across the way? You have to go to the teleporter. Yeah
Oh wait, there's a teleporter
Oh ain't that nifty right where's the lights? Oh, did somebody already fix them?
Yes
If you'd kill me she'd be I'm I'm just the Avenger bro
I'm captain america
I have america's ass
I'm looking for I'm looking for a dead
Oh, not a dead body. I'm looking for someone to avenge
What
Is
Uh, okay, then it's probably naya
I think azura might be fine because I was alone with her for a bit
But she might have been biding her time and marinating me. Um, I'm gonna find naya
Where's naya she must be on the other side still
I
Don't know
Where's the life support
Of course, it's across the way I bet
It is isn't it? Oh, hopefully somebody figures that out
Oh
Where how do we get over there? Oh, I'm gonna watch you we got to get over there to the ship
Uh-huh
I
Amazing job detective amazing job
I got a skedaddle
But it's been really fun. Thank you for inviting me to this really fun collab. I wish I could stay longer
Bye everybody kisses
Discord
I
I've been like I gotta go feed my cat. Um
That was fun. I like the addition of the more roles. It's just like it's funny because like
I used to play a lot of town of salem
Um, and then like among us came out and it's like, oh, this is moving around town of salem with extra stuff
And now like there's goose goose duck which is really I'm happy these things are like free because this is a this is a really fun game
um, I definitely um
Play with those girls again. It's so funny. I think it makes sense actually to have a larger group for this just because the maps are so huge
um
Whereas for like among us like it makes sense to have like just eight people or whatever the heck
excuse me
Yeah, I know there's like a town of salem too
But yeah, everybody's so cute as geese. Yeah, it's super fun. I'm super tired. Um
So I'm gonna go feed the baby the baby fia
My kitty cat and I'm gonna literally just like pass out boomi is sitting next. Well, he's not sitting
He is knocked out himself in the cat bed on my desk. Um, I just realized that there's icing on my
Ring light that's cute. Uh, I also I just keep finding cake pieces in random places by the way. It's really fun
It's like cake in my bathroom. There's cake in my closet. I don't even know how it got there. There's cake everywhere
um
But uh, it's literally I just noticed that it's like what the heck
Because it had it at an angle and then I think boomi must have bumped it when he walked over so no I could see it
The non-members don't know they don't know. Um, but I'm glad you guys enjoyed
Um, it is uh my day off tomorrow. So I'll probably I'll be getting like a lot of stuff down and record some stuff
um
Yeah
I've been watch I've been binge watching the uh the kingdom the last kingdom on netflix
Because I've been on like a vikings-esque kick
And I'm like, yeah, it's okay. Uh, are you doing anything monday?
So we're doing the members stream monday that will be I call it member mondays or
Doing a megan a stupid little doll horror movie watch along and I'm gonna wear the heart rate monitor again
um
But I don't do I only have the members stream? I think so. It might be just the members stream
Um, but yeah, no, I've never seen that movie. It looks really dumb
So and I hate how hyper realistic the doll is so I maybe I'll actually be scared
Uh, yes 4 p.m
4 p.m. Member mondays
Will you hold me during the movie you get scared easy? You're gonna be scared of a little doll. Are you sure?
You probably cried during anvil
It's the best kind of dumb. I heard it was like surprisingly an okay movie
I won't be scared. I know I'm probably just gonna be sitting there just being like, what is this?
I'm not projecting
Uh
I liked that I walked past rain and she was talking about liking chocolate bunnies and I was like yelp
That was a lot of good clips and moments in this
I hope somebody makes the highlights out of it
With that'll be a lot of work with the multiple povs. Um, it's also really cool being able to hang out with um
The v and u girls, uh, I don't often get to do that. Um, I think that was my first
collab
I might be wrong
These are blur, um, and then just like some new people like I didn't know that we had spanish speakers
So that was pretty cool. Um
And then yeah, it's a lot of really cool people
Um, it sucks that like irie irie's internet just went out and then reya couldn't make it because uh, she wasn't feeling well
The poor jote. Yeah first v and u collab. Yeah, I've talked to serenity like outside of like an online collab
That's why I got confused
um really briefly, um
But it was cool
I think it's really nice doing collabs and stuff because I think again it shows people that velar is pretty normal
Like I'm sitting here and I'm expecting this very say so collab and people are just like farting and like swearing and being like
Like before before call. There's so many innuendos and I'm like
What collab is this?
I'm like, I know I wasn't gonna be like I thought I was in the horpo. What's happening here, but it's
Um, but it was I think it shows people that were just very very chill. Um
It's I'm I try to really behave myself in um collabs not that
Yeah, it's not hard to do though. Like I'm I'm a pretty well behaved person
I'd like to say
you know
Just your regular
I think my favorite thing is just hearing imi just scream my name
That sounds really weird out of context would just be like
Just like she gets so panicked and it's so funny. Oh my god. No, it's not
Ah, you have to like shout over her. It's so funny. I like shout over some of them
She's like very it's like she immediately starts panicking and yelling
And then as there is this like I just wanted you dead. I'm like, yo, okay. Damn was there
It's coming at me
um
For no reason. I'm just sitting here minding my lonesome checking you guys out
Um, but lots of yeah, it was fun. I like the carnival map. It was pretty cool
Oh
Hardest line she ever dropped. I got so hurt. I got shot through the heart
Um
Yeah, as there as there like locks in during these games. She's very as her is just a good gamer to be honest
Um, I think she hides her power level in that regard
It's like certain games like certain like like like uh competitive games. She's like very very good at um
Do you give love a bad name? I'd hope not
Yeah, she is a menace
menace
Uh, and the mercy was funny too. I really wanted to get mercy when I was the duck and when she was like
She'd be hypothetically. Um, what if I was the
The kill it out. I wish I could have turned around be like no mercy. Don't and then she'd be like
And there's like get her
Uh, but yeah, mercy just screaming. She like laughed for like two minutes straight
brain
Uh, there's definitely a lot of clippable moments definitely a lot of clippable moments. I really wish um
Strani was in the stream because again, I love strani in these types of games
She's just me screaming and I just got like she's just like a like ivy. She's just like ivy
Um, it's so funny mercy and serenity. They're so like
Literally joined at the hip. I love their friendship so much
um
I hope that I can build a friendship like that with somebody. I feel like I'm on my way with building
friendships with some of the girls that close
um
Obviously, obviously I'm close to the viewer girls. I mean like outside of the company. Uh, so it'll be really cool
Although it's funny my dad. I went out he like called me before he went to the movies
And he's like I was talking about I'm like, yeah, I have a collab today and then uh,
And I was hanging out I was talking about like I was hanging out with tomah
And I'm like, yeah, it was such a fun stream and my dad's just like have you been outside and I'm like
Yeah
Uh, he's like
I'm like, yeah, which is a grocery store
And he's like no like have you like gone outside?
For like a walk or something just like leave your home and I'm like
No
Dad I'm neat maxing my dad. What the hell does neat maxing mean?
And I'm like I'll like go I don't like dad well
Hara I just like to say Hara. I'm like my my viewers got me like this like new like chairs
Like I said on my balcony. He's like that's not what I mean
He's like you need to leave your house
And I'm like but fee has been sick. He's like, okay fine. I'll give you that and I'm like
Okay
Have you literally have you touched grass have you touched grace?
And then this guy goes home and he's like, oh, I have a call of duty update to play
And I'm like
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, bro. Whatever
I'm a gamer. You're a gamer
You can't treat me this way
And like before he hung up. He's like, you know, I don't I'm not trying to like kill you or anything
He's like, you know, even though you don't live under my roof anymore. I'm still your father and I was like
Okay, yeah, you're right. I have to go outside. He's like a support for your mental and I'm like, yeah
Okay, then I'll go for a walk or something
There's a park nearby my house. So maybe I'll walk to the park
um
250 literally I have I have caught on my computer and I'm gonna uninstall it because it's like swallow. I think it's like
ridiculously swallowed up one of my
my uh hard drives
or my ssd
Like yeah, what do you expect at work from home? Like it's like I'm a I'm a streamer. I'm a niche internet celebrity dad
okay
All right, and I might be doing things so I can support fias medical bills. Okay
um
Finally we get some maybe I'll do a
Twitter space and be like hey you guys are coming on a walk with me
Maybe that'll be good actually because it is true. Like I have been like cooped up in my house a lot
Um, I am hanging out with friends soon like going out to lunch with them
But again, it's different because again, I used to have hobbies where I'd be like hiking or I'd be doing jiu-jitsu
Or I'd be outside gardening with my mom
But just because I've been really isolated. I haven't really felt the need to go outside
So I'm like awkward
But like I definitely need to do that because I don't have anything to do anything
anyone let like
Like the people I would normally hang out with to do those things like I just really don't talk to anymore. So
Um
Honestly, this is not bad, but it's it's not that bad, but my dad knows me very well
He he knows that I need to go outside and touch grass
Uh, because sometimes it's like oh
It's not good for me personally to like isolate for so long. Not that I'm doing it on purpose
It's really that I've been so busy and that's what I explained to my dad
I'm like, I'm just really really busy and I'm like, hey man
I hate you up so we could go out and watch Deadpool. All right, so like I'm trying here
Because I'm a terrible communicator
And I hate texting people
Or just communicating in general
I'm just
I this time again, I'm an introvert
And I was way more of an extrovert when I worked at my sales job
But now since I work from home and I just talk on the internet
I can just be back to my introvert itself
And it's great
Have you talked to Salem I talked to Salem um and all of yesterday because we were making plans
Uh, and I was telling them I was up with Fia. Uh, I'm taking out
All I was getting married
So I'm taking her out
To a nice restaurant because I wasn't able to make her bachelorette because I was at my grandparents house
In florida during her bachelorette weekend
Which was a bummer
But I'm also kind of happy that I didn't go because it was on a boat and I would have puked
Because I'm not good. You guys know I get really freaking motion sick. I probably would have died
But it looked fun otherwise like there was other parts when they weren't on a boat
So I'm like, oh
And I dressed up like the cheetah girls. It was so cute. I'm like, what the hell
What the heck man is Salem auditioning? I that's why I like I Salem's not gonna audition
No, Salem's not gonna audition the project that I have working on with her
Um is going to take a very long time and a like a lot of money because I would I would want her to get like a
Png youtuber model or I would get her like, I don't know. Maybe I just get our booth model and she could customize it
um
Because we wanted to do a podcast together talking about like uh books and stuff our favorite schmottie books, um
Boomi is hanging off the edge of the bed off my desk because a little pa is touching me. I'm gonna shake your hand. Hello, sir
Oh
Oh, she's a good boy today. He was actually no
You were annoying because you kept trying to steal your sister's food again
Yeah, I'm talking about you. Um
But that will take a really long time and I already have another project I'm working on before that
Um, I haven't had time to talk to Salem
Because everybody's so busy like now that we don't work together at the same job because me and olive and salem
I always still work at the same job. Um
Uh, it's harder to like get together
Not that like and I'm also just a terrible texture. Like they text pretty fine. I miss a terrible texture
um
Call that literature
I'm stealing that. Thank you. Um
For me accusations. I was telling my dad about how someone is like just like boomi's lawyer
And he was dying laughing. He thought that was really funny
I forgot I wanted to ask him to record a voice message of like to say hi to you guys, but I totally forgot about that
um
Maybe it's for the best people probably be like, oh my god, male. Although it's like literally my dad's
I might just do it with my mom and dad just so people feel okay
Um
Yeah, no me and my dad saw Deadpool today. It was great. I
Blew my expectation. I went with no expectations
Uh and very low expectations actually but I blew it out of the water. I just
Oh my god, it made me like
like
desire
rewatching all the x-men movies again, like if I could although they're terrible but like
Like x uh x-men like the last day. I was the first ever superhero movie I watched so it has this uh,
A soft spot in my heart
Spart you guys know what I mean spot. Um
Yeah, they're really good like and I liked all the nods to like their mess ups
And past the movie like I'm not looking forward to the next phases
I was looking forward to Thunderbolts as I mentioned on my twitter and then they
Totally messed like the casting is trash if they had like Scream and Mimi
Goliath
Zemo
Uh fixture or whatever the heck their names is. I can't remember anymore. Um, because I haven't read the comics a bit
But I was like, what is this cat? Like they're all it's like taskmaster times three
They all have the same freaking power like they don't even have any powers. They're all just marksmen
And I'm like stop age of alternate has made a resurgence as well has it now
Um, I remember yeah, I saw the trailer for like world war. No not world war hulk. Um
What is that?
Falcon movie
There's a captain almost a captain falcon, um ever get
Like in the trailer you see a glimpse of red hulk and that is would be the only reason why I would go
And I'm really surprised that um
What's his face is in the movie because I felt like he's just like over like I thought he would never ever be in the MCU because
Yeah
Yeah, brave new worlds. Thank you. I'm like
I didn't even finish like
Falcon
And that winter soldier like I just didn't even finish that because it was boring to me
and
I hated I
Hated the scrawl
TV show they had
Even though Amelia Clark was in it. I'm like I watched two episodes and I'm like this is trash
I watched like three episodes or four episodes of hawkeye. I'm like I'm bored
I like all the tv shows just
Fell off the movies fell off
um
Like and like I used to be a freaking huge mc mcu fan like huge huge
mcu fan
But I like oh it just is not
Good and then like I really like Eternals
Like felt like it was the catalyst of the beginning of the end
Um, I love the casting the Eternals like got Barry Keegan. He got the dude from uh game of thrones
he got
uh
that one chick
Whose name escapes me that's been in a bunch of other stuff. She was in
The creator which was the creator made me ball my eyes out
Great movie by the way. Holly would recommend watch the creator
um
It's all downhill from endgame. I thought they're okay. Like I think I was more around
I've been if I watched it again and game I'd be like, what is this?
But like because of the hype and stuff. I think I enjoyed it
Yeah, I was
pissed that they recasted
him as doom to be honest
Uh
Just because I would have loved a fresh new face for doom. That's really the only personal reason for me
and um
Also seeing how much he's getting paid. I'm like jesus christ
Uh, I'm curious to see like if they may come some sort of variant
or if
It would be super cool if he's a variant like oh, what if stark became doom or something because I'm pretty sure that is like a
what-if comic? I don't know. Um
And or
If he just has the same face and it'll be cool if they like see him and they're just like, oh wait a second
That looks like
A stark and then maybe they like I don't know lose their minds. I don't know
They got him for doom so they can get more people to watch it too
But like oh like they've already watched it for pager pascal like I'm so excited pager pascals in it
I don't know. So like I like pager pascal and the invisible woman's actress whose name also escapes me
I don't know who the other two people are that are in the fantastic four
um
I didn't see the fantastic four with the michael b jordan
Because it looked terrible
Although I love jamey bell
Because I really one of my guilty pleasure movies is jumper with hating christensen. I freaking love jumper
They should make a second jumper movie
Jumper was so cool
I remember basing uh, I made like a
Like I remember I told you guys about like my um young justice fan fiction
I made another character that was like teleportation the same exact way from like jumper
Jumper is such a good movie
No loop the looper is different. There's something called jumper with hating christensen. You're thinking of
Whatever that dude's name is I was calling paul rudd. That's not the case
um
But yeah, no jumper was good and uh
Yeah, I was just like
I don't know why but like tenet just popped into my head for whatever reason
I'm waiting for tenet two to come out
I've seen tenet like three times and it gets better every time I watch it
And I don't know why for christopher nola movie
I think it was scored so low because it was hard to follow. That's why like after the third watch
I started to enjoy it more. Uh tenet
If you repeat you
You don't have to remind me. I know but thank you
Um, I'll be honest. I wish
You would stop telling me that I should be doing something when I kind of just want to talk for a moment
She's fine. So I appreciate it, but you don't have to baby me. I am a grown woman
I will leave when I need to
Needing to watch it like three times was my issue
But like I was just great every time and I can't wait because then the second movie is going to start where the like
Is going to start at the beginning of the first movie essentially
Um, it's okay, but I think I've gotten you don't have to remind because I think it also bothers people who enjoy the app
Uh, I'm aware fia is napping right now. Anyways, I can see her on the couch
And I have to hold her like a baby to feed her
Um, but yeah
I think of
On him again, I'm excited to see alien romulus
She's a good poof indeed
I like I've been having to do this thing. It's she like I literally have to have her like a little baby
It's like I'm raising a baby because I have to hold her like a baby and bottle feeder or I have to syringe feeder because she can't um
Eat right now that well
Because her uh the muscles again are not responding
But she can like drink and like do other stuff or whatever. She just can't like
chew
So I've like literally made like
Whipped together like pureed her food to the extreme and put it in a syringe
And then I hold it like a little baby and then I burp her and then I put her in the litter box
See if she needs to go and then
I tuck her in and then I like play with a little bit with her
Oh, yeah, I'm sitting in the theater with my dad watching the trailer for romulus. He's like, I can't watch this
I can't do it. I'm like dad. He's like
I hate these movies
I don't like that because my dad my dad is such a big baby. He's scared of like uh like um
Any sort of horror movie except for like I think my dad can handle like slasher films
He was belly laughing so hard in the opening scene. I was like dad, please
You are perpetuating a certain stereotype and you need to be quiet
He's like, I just can't help it. It's so funny and I'm like I understand
Um
Especially because like my dad's belly laugh sounds like what's his face from the Simpsons sometimes
Because your life like super high-pitched um
Um
My dad does that voice a lot too, you know when he's when I do something stupid. He'll just laugh at me like that
um
But yeah, no, it was fun because like I knew there's so oh my god, that's the easter eggs
The easter. Yeah, Nelson the easter eggs. I was like Nelson, right? Yeah, Nelson, but I didn't say it
The easter eggs in Deadpool were awesome like me and my dad were like that Leonardo DiCaprio me and we were like, oh
Um
If we brought my mom my mom would probably would have fainted from all the gorge
Uh, the fight choreography was really good
The the sexual tension between Deadpool and Wolverine was palpable
During their fight scenes. There's like one part and I think a lot of people cut it
um like they cut
and like like they clipped it
uh
where their
Spoilers by the way, although I'm it's in like the trailer
um
Then they're fighting in the minivan and he just like gets a little grin on his face when they're fighting
I remember seeing a tweet someone saying oh he a freak freak and I'm like hell yeah
um
But it was funny because it looked
Like that wasn't scripted like it's very slight that you could see the smile
uh
They paid a great homage to the Spider-Man fellow Deadpool's dodges and Wolverine
um
it was
Yeah, that was yeah, they come back and they were like the
You guys can't see me, but I have my hand. I'm hoping that leads to more Deadpool team-up movies
There is so much love that was put into that movie
I could tell like there's again lots of homage like the ending credit scene where they kind of cycle through all the fox 20th century fox
MCU stuff
That was really cool to see because you literally just saw all the multiverse behind the scene clips and it was so awesome
um
But I really hope that opens up like a Deadpool Spider-Man
Like it would be it would be so freaking hilarious if it's Deadpool and Tom Holland's Spider-Man
Or even Andrew Garfield's Spider-Man
Uh, because you know, there would be like a cameo of like Toby or Andrew Garfield or Tom Holland depending on which one
And it would be funny if it was Tom Holland because then like Deadpool will just be going around swearing and killing people
And then you could see Tom Holland's Spider-Man going like no you can't do that like come on
And like maybe like not doing anything the entire film and then like randomly dropping an f-bomb perhaps like like at the very end
Or like like like I think that would be so fun
Um, Andrew Andrew would be perfect out of all of them. Andrew would be the best
Um, in my opinion. I heard aren't they going to make another spider-man film with Andrew?
um
I think because he got like a lot of love from the spider-verse
Not the spider-verse the you guys multiverse of that. I can't remember. I can't get my stuff together
I'm excited for the into the spider-verse the next one though because
damn
Andrew does deserve a third honestly, I liked Andrew Garfield's spider-man
uh
Yeah, no way home. Sorry. I'm like the heck uh
I am obsessed with the soundtrack of the second movie. I will play
Electro's theme
And just get in my head and just be like
Like it's like dubstep versus like with orchestral and I'm like, oh, I'm so hype
I even ended up like memorizing all the lyrics and I'll just sing it
Like I just love Electro's theme. It's so sick to me
like Hans Zimmer just
Chef's kiss anything he touches
turns to gold
I remember watching like an analysis of him creating like prior to the Caribbean theme and I'm like
Of course that was Hans Zimmer because I initially didn't know that he scored that
um, he does and he like
the
Like go go. What do you have the chance and just it's eight minutes long listen to Electro's theme
And it's great or just the scene where um, he like officially becomes electro
Um, but yeah, no like no way home is also a good movie
That was a great movie
I get so nostalgic when I watch certain movies like I wanted to ball my eyes out
um
in like the
Final stretch of the Deadpool Mulvane movie because I'm just like
This is so I just want to cry everywhere because I was so happy and it just made me so nostalgic
All these MC movies no ultimate alliance game. That's a good point. There must be some sort of licensing thing
You think that'd be like place somewhere
Shibi, how did you understand that one guy whose name I must say you couldn't I don't know I just because
And it's funny because it's like that actor so it's like 10 times funnier to me
Although I thought like I it would have been really funny if they brought in
uh
X-Men Origins version too like because I like I also really liked that character because of X-Men Origins
I had a big crush when I was younger on the X-Men X-Men Origins
Wolverine version of that character. Um
I also liked him and John Carter because you know
I told you Maguire was in that too. It was in John Carter. Um
But yeah, no, it was so funny
And I don't even remember the context of why they were that character
Why he was that character because I remember he's always loved that character
And I can't remember if I like read somewhere. He always begged to be the mcu
Like if you like just make me him and he finally got it
But it's like it's it's that actor and it
He's usually in totally different things, but it's kind of funny. Like this is who he is in the mcu
Um X-Men Origins. Yes
Yes, they had like oh my god
if they had like
Um, honestly if they had like leave Shriverman or like his name is Shriver left Shriver who played um
So they were too good as well. That'd be cool. They had a lot. They literally brought back like all the
Brotherhood um
People and I was like staring at pyro for the longest time because I'm like
Who is this who?
Who I can't remember their name. Who are they and then they said that I was like, oh
uh
Yeah, oh, I literally like screamed and clapped when that happened because I'm I usually don't but I had to like that was the
iconic moment
Ghost rider would have been funny if you'd like randomly had like nick cage. That would have been hilarious
Um
Good night. How's it going?
Welcome I'm about to end very soon. In fact, I should probably find somebody to rain
Um, but yeah, there's a lot of cool easter eggs. It was interesting. Was that
Mephisto
as the red
Guy it was Mephisto fellies. I can't remember pronounce the name Mephisto
I don't know. Oh, it was Azazel. Oh, I always get them confused. I always think their
Names. Yeah, it was Azazel
Yeah from first class, I haven't remembered first class for the longest time
And who is the guy in the beginning with the I remember he I don't know
I haven't watched the latest X-Men movies like the newer ones except for first class and um
The second one after that like I didn't see dark phoenix. I didn't see apocalypse. I like fell asleep during it because it was horrible
um
No, I'm gonna pull this shut up. Um
Yes, that is true. He did
Thanks for that image. I appreciate it. Um
Oh
I love night night carl is one of as
Like between him and gambit. They are my favorite
characters
and um
in marvel
Uh, I used to literally be so obsessed with night crawler
My dad's like, why do you like a blue guy and I'm like, I don't know dad. I don't know what to tell you
I
Miss equals also gave made me very confused
Yeah, I actually didn't like him in the live action movies
I've only ever liked him in the cartoons in the comics
Yeah, oh, yeah, there's so many spider spider invariance
That's why I feel like you can like because they introduced the tv
You can literally bring in so much stuff
Oh, yeah rouge
Ruse dancing scene x-men evolution. Oh ruse. Oh g uh rouge. Why am I saying rouge rogue?
I'm so stupid. I'm thinking because of rouge the bat because we were talking about ruse the bat earlier. Um
He gets headaches too much in the movie
Oh
What do you wait, what about wait is are they from this is changing to you know from who is he actually caging because that would be funny
um
Yeah, be on the spider verse cannot wait
He's k what I thought the accent was pretty like it was
Good because it's really what those people sound like
I don't know. I just understand it. I don't know
But it's I just see all the memes on twitter because that that's what was spoiled for me
And I'm like, okay. I know I have to see it in theaters if they are in it
Um, sorry spoiler somebody posted in the freaking chat
Um, what do you want people?
Oh
And like I love the actress that played rogue in the movies because she was in true blood and I love true blood
I like love true blood so much
So
Okay, what time is it 12 36 in a pack one. Yeah
She I don't even know what she's up to lately. What was it in a pack went up to
What do you do in girly pop?
All right, I'm gonna go watch the kingdom as I feed fia because again, she's like a baby
So I'm gonna bottle feed her while I watch stuff. I'm just I'm just a great mom, you know
um
Thank you for letting me geek out with you about some Marvel stuff at the ends
I also got a pee
I'll be bottle fed. I'll bottle feed you with something else. What? Okay. Bye. Let me find someone to read
Well, I'm drinking excuse me
I
La la
Let's see are any of the girls still on they are they're still playing
Oh, I'm just gonna redirect into a zero
Because she I bet she's still talking actually
Oh
She's talking like I am right now
Wait, are they hold on I can just look at the chat. Yes. I'm right. Okay. Uh
Is there a probably will chat for longer? She's still yapping. Okay. I'll motivate her till you have more
Okay. Bye guys. Me lucky. See you. Bye. Bye. Have a good night. Bye
Later
You